you can't make a great horror movie
without also making a few mistakes the
final girl bursts out laughing during a
big escape seen the blood spewing
machine malfunctions and saturates the
entire set the flesh-eating swamp
monster trips over his own tentacles and
falls down a flight of stairs sometimes
these clips get relegated for the gag
reel while in other cases they're so
good they end up in the final film
either way here's a look at some great
bloopers that will change the way you
see these horror movies the cabin in the
woods Josh Whedon 2012 entry into the
horror genre was typically
tongue-in-cheek filled with intentional
hilarious subversions of various scary
movie tropes including the epic finale
in which a virtual encyclopedia of
monsters escaped on their cells and
annihilate the technicians who have been
holding them captive
but while the carnage of that last act
was planned one of its best scenes was a
beneficiary of a happy little accident
specifically we're talking about the
scene where actor Bradley Whitford was
eaten by the mermen the death itself was
cool but the best part is what comes
after
the blow hole shooting blood is
hilarious but it's also not what the
filmmakers originally planned with only
the one scene to shoot the effects crew
decided to use their entire remaining
supply of fake blood so instead of a
little burp of blood the Merman blew
like Old Faithful and kept on blowing
until the blood ran out and the guys are
like effect was replaced by a farty red
mist
effects master David Leroy Anderson of
afx later said I love the wide shot in
the behind-the-scenes video where the
blood keeps going and going because it
reminds me of that night which was just
hysterical I kept thinking how are they
going to use this he's sitting there
flapping like a fish and it looks like a
hose spraying blood everywhere but the
way they cut it together was perfect
scream in 1996
where's Kraven send-up of the slasher
genre heralded the dawn of a new wave of
smart sleek self-aware horror films
the special effects however were the
same tried-and-true practical techniques
directors have relied on for years
including the use of corn syrup to
simulate blood and then a movie where it
seemed like someone was stabbed to death
every other minute things are extremely
sloppy and sticky on set by the time the
film reached its thrilling climax this
led to a hilarious unplanned exchange
when Skeet Ulrich lost control of the
blood-covered phone and accidentally
winged it right at Matthew Lillard head
leading to a very genuine reaction from
the surprised actor everywhere thus far
ordinarily an outburst like that might
have led to a shouts of cuts and a
request to do the scene again but
according to the screen DVD commentary
occurs the Lillard was supposed to be
playing the duty sidekick to all rich
his cold-blooded psychopath his reaction
wasn't out of character
Traven went ahead and kept it safely off
the cutting room floor as it turns out
it was a wise move not only did the line
make it to the final cut it's one of the
funniest moments in the movie another of
the funny at the moment and scream can
only be seen in the blooper reel though
and it comes courtesy of the director
himself
where's Kraven who also directed the
classic A Nightmare on Elm Street made a
cameo in scream dressed as nightmare
villain of Freddy Krueger that was fun
enough but in one L take he demonstrated
a gift for physical comedy that fans
have made the final film scream three
the third entry in the scream franchise
was also improved by an on-camera
mistake the exciting conclusion to Wes
Craven's scream trilogy is full of
scripted suspense but one of its most
action-packed fight scenes has a big
blooper right in the middle according to
an encyclopaedia collection of scream 3
trivia the confrontation between Neve
Campbell and Scott Foley includes an
actual genuine stabbing in the moment
where Sidney leaps over a bar and nails
Roman in the back with an ice pick Foley
was wearing a protective pad for the
scene but Campbell mr. mark and plunged
the pick into Foley's actual flesh no
wonder his scream of surprise and pain
seemed so genuine the descent a
terrifying movie in which a bunch of
young women are stalked and killed while
exploring a darkened cave system it gets
even more frightening when the descends
adds in a bunch of subterranean monsters
wanting to eat their delicious flesh
that's why it's so funny on the blooper
reel when one of the victims whose faces
or deformed from unspeakable things
gives one of the humans an unexpected
moment of romance
[Music]
House of Wax
the 2005 remake of the 50s horror
classic House of Wax
starred WB heartthrobs such as Chad
Michael Murray from One Tree Hill Jared
Padalecki from Gilmore Girls and the
socialite reality star and a
night-vision camera owner Paris Hilton
to her credit the often dispassionate
Hilton gives everything she's got to her
performance as a scream queen shrieking
bloody murder as a script requires the
screaming is intentionally annoying but
still not nearly as annoying as the
actual car alarm that went off during a
scene in the woods ruining the shot
scream for acting can be magical when a
director gets a perfect believable
reaction from a performer like one of
objects Tara in a horror movie for
example or you can just pull a prank on
an actor on a set of a horror movie and
scare him for real on the set of scream
4 Eric Knudsen was apparently supposed
to open a door and find nothing bear
instead of nothing however there was
something something actually pretty
frightening especially if you're not
expecting it Halloween star Malcolm
McDowell is always an imposing presence
who dominates every scene he's in
whether he's playing the hero an
antihero or a villain in Rob Zombie's
2007 version of Halloween he plays dr.
Samuel Loomis the former psychiatrist of
crazed the murderer Michael Myers
Mya's eventually comes for dr. Loomis of
course and he cowers in fear in a
darkened house but when Maya smashes
through the door to get him McDowell
seems taken off-guard apparently he
didn't realize they were filming that
bit yet that Halloween reboot must have
been a pretty lively set to work on
because it's blooper reel offers up
another goofy I'll take what's so funny
about being stabbed
as far as actor Ken Foree is concerned
everything while Michael Myers
repeatedly stabs him with a prop knife
and fake blood audibly uses everywhere
for a gets a case of the giggles that
simply
won't die Jennifer's body
oscar-winner Diablo Cody wrote the
screenplay for Jennifer's body which
offered character relationships a bit
more complex than those in the average
horror movie over the course of the film
nerdy Anita played by Amanda Seyfried
comes to both love and hate her best
friend popular cheerleader turned a
murderous succubus Jennifer played by
Megan Fox those mixed feelings
physically manifest in a scene in which
psy Fred screens accusatory things at
Fox's character and then kisses her or
at least she tries to kiss her as Fox
has apparently so deep in a monstrous
character that she takes a bite out of a
coaster I actually bet her I'm sorry the
which one of the most truly haunting
horror movies in years was the witch
it features an atmospheric setting in
colonial Massachusetts and it's paired
with the scary premise that the witches
of the Salem witch trial error just
might have been real there's a ton of
weird stuff in the witch from dark woods
to kidnapping to naked people drinking
blood to a goat named the black Philip
that a pair of creepy twin phase talks
for them yeah but what's not so scary
though horses particularly horses
needing to hear about their horse bodily
functions with no regard for the very
expensive film production happening
right in front of them you don't let me
along with you
Alec mother and father this instance
The Silence of the Lambs Anthony Hopkins
deservedly won an Academy Award for Best
Actor for his performance of
cannibalistic serial killer Hannibal
Lecter in the Silence of the Lambs
famously it was one of only a handful of
horror movies to ever take home major
Oscars Hopkins as one of the best actors
in the world and as such is quite
versatile he played an American
president and Nixon and the repressed
English Butler and the remains of the
day he even played Rocky Balboa once no
really he did well his face and shirts
were covered in blood during a twisted
and hilarious out fake on the set of The
Silence of the Lambs
he brought his inner rocky out for the
world to see this one is for you it in
you Paulie
let's go through Rocky [ __ ] let's do it
no go-go's in the books even cannibals
need to laugh now and then Shaun of the
Dead zombie driven horror comedy Shaun
of the Dead made a movie star out of
Simon Pegg it's also reunited the actor
with his collaborators from the cult of
British sitcom space including director
Edgar Wright and co-star Nick Frost
they're all good friends and seem to
share the same comedy hivemind which
means taken Frost are frequently
ad-libbed and goofed off on the set of
Shaun of the Dead ruining takes but
cracking up each other and anybody else
in the vicinity now I don't reckon the
rest of the gang on Walking Dead just
try that next time thanks for watching
click the loop icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know you're not too
[Music]